I wish that this was not a real story
but Donald Trump has blamed Canada for
burning down the white house in 1812 and
not only did he do that he did it while
on the phone with the Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau as I've talked
about Donald Trump is putting these new
tariffs on Canada and on Mexico and on
the European Union and Donald Trump said
that one of the reasons for those new
tariffs was national security that was
part of the motivation you could say for
his decision and he had a phone call
with Justin Trudeau and Trudeau rightly
so asked can you explain what you mean
by you're putting tariffs on Canada for
national security reasons and Donald
Trump said according to multiple sources
familiar with the discussion
didn't you guys burn down the White
House and of course it was the British
or at least individuals who were had
pledged allegiance to the British and
not Canadians who burned down the White
House during the war of ain't 1812
actually the burning happened in 1814 as
part of the war of 1812 and it was
actually more complicated because it was
liberated slaves in the from the United
States who escaped and joined up with
the British who actually torched the
White House in 1814 but again as far as
national allegiance goes it was Britain
not Canada and here's the funniest part
of the entire thing this is from the
original CNN article explaining what
took place quote when asked if the
comment was received as a joke by Justin
Trudeau of course one source on the call
said to the degree one can ever take
what is said as a joke the impact on
Canada and ultimately on workers in the
u.s. won't be a laughing matter so
there's a couple layers here right the
fact that Trump thinks Canada burned
down the White House in 1812 makes him
completely ignorant of the facts the
fact that that was the only reason that
he could come up with four national
security-related tariffs on Canada makes
him dangerous right the context is what
makes it totally insane aside from it
being wrong the President of the United
States is imposing tariffs on Canada
because if something he believes they
did 206 years ago which actually
happened 204 years ago and most
importantly was done by somebody else
this is idiocracy how does the next
president of the United States clean up
this mess and I've been saying this
increasingly over the last couple of
weeks the biggest indictment here is on
the nearly 40% of Americans that support
this buffoonery and in the same way that
you can't reason with people that have
extraordinarily lacking intellectual
faculties you cannot reason with someone
who thinks not only that Canada burned
down the White House more than two
hundred years ago but that if it were
true it would justify steel tariffs in
2018 you just can't justify it if that
justifies steel tariffs on Canada we
could have no relationship with Japan or
Germany or I mean it's it's a very long
list of countries well I think you said
it as a joke and the reason why he made
this joke was because he didn't have a
real argument his line about tariffs is
that all these other countries have a
major trading surplus with the United
States right we're at a trading deficit
but you can't make that argument with
Canada because it seems like they
actually export more than the import so
yeah it was it was his fall back it
wasn't true that he necessarily believed
that Canada torched the White House but
even if it was true that he believed
that it's not really what makes him
think we need tariffs on Canada like
it's just because of the trade imbalance
and he's saying well you guys did
something to us more than two hundred
years ago I do think he's ignorant of
history like maybe he did think that the
Canadians actually torched the White
House but that wasn't an actual reason
he was offering to Trudeau it was just a
way to brush it off and when you know
people's jobs and livelihoods are at
stake that's not acceptable you know I
want to say thank you I was in Montreal
for Memorial Day weekend everybody there
was super nice and I want to thank
everybody there for being nice to us
because at this point who could really
blame Canadians for by mere osmosis
starting to treat us like crap when we
go over there because this is a level of
buffoonery and hostility in general but
specifically towards Canada that we've
not seen I mean I can't think of a
president that has behaved this way
towards Canada . right like i'm guessing
at some point in history there's
examples we can point to but certainly
not while I've been alive like South
Park blame Canada for everything that's
what he's doing I never watch that show
but I take your word for it that that is
something from the show yeah friend and
I know a lot of people in the audience
do like it and are angry with me that I
don't watch South Park but I don't I've
not been able to sit more through more
than a few minutes of it ever
I just just can't do it folks the video
you just finished watching was made
possible by you through the membership
program you can sign up for membership
at david pakman.com slash membership we
are viewer supported independent media
you can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership